so so hard not to sing the songs that I
want to be serenading you with very
factually later actually like how do I
say like an in a stated way instead of a
singing way start with the word serenade
but that's that's the irony though it's
funny right because I'm starin a ting
you by staying words and so singing them
cuz isn't that what a joke is it's like
the contrast between whatever podcast
where I stink at making jokes all right
guys we have another awesome podcast for
you today almost say that every single
time because every podcast is awesome
but it's weird for us we're so good at
words but today we're gonna be mainly
talking about like moving our dream shop
potentially in the future and we're
gonna chat with her friend April who
actually has built her dream shop so
she's gone through it so it'll be
interesting to get her perspective on
what the process was like for her April
Wilkerson she's you don't know there's
only one April in the world one of my
favorites
it's another music based game and it's
one that we've done before and it's
where we just say the words instead of
singing them and then we need to guess
what the actual song is yeah but it is
really hard because I just want to sing
them right now I've been like listening
to them let's do an intro for April so
April April Wilkerson she has a channel
on YouTube and she makes lots of
different types of things like she
builds insane structures she does a lot
of woodworking metalworking she's really
good at welding yes just come up with a
few of her own like really cool original
designs yeah she's like so impressive
she's very like she just makes crazy
big stuff I mean she makes smaller
thanks to but but they're the cool thing
she sets new limits for herself and what
she can take on and everything and she
recently built I don't even know how big
it is but it's like a giant it's bigger
than her house it's bigger than our
house
it's a giant with a giant shop she built
herself she had like a couple people
come and help out but it wasn't like
hiring it out like she that everything
it's crazy so so we first the first time
we met April it was we have like we did
like a Skype call or something how'd it
happen to her we reached out to her it
was it was pretty early in our like
YouTube history um and it was cuz we had
gotten reached out to it was like the
first time we got reached out to you by
a production company interested in
pitching a show to us and doing like uh
sizzle reel for us and this wasn't the
story that we told in like episode it
was so this is our very first one and we
never we were like what's going on what
is life what is reality well and we knew
that April had just done a show and had
I think a pilot come out for for this
show that she had tried out and I don't
think the show panned out right I don't
know oh boy
at the time it was it was just in in
pilot mode and we're like oh we we just
saw in line that she had just done this
would all be really fresh
I wonder she'll talk to us about her
experience and even though we had never
I mean we'd kind of like chatted and
comments very very we were small fries
at that point right we were very small
yeah we had very just barely chatted in
comments that she was nice enough to
have like we probably had it for like an
hour in a video chat just talking about
like TV behind the scenes stuff and TV
versus YouTube and things to watch out
for if you're talking to there's a lot
to watch out for I'm not sure how much
we talked about in the last episode but
like you know who owns the rights to
your merch or something you know because
we're Evan and Caitlin we saw epidemic
in March now we're bringing that brand
to the show but like so can write it
into the contract that they are making
your brand like a bigger thing so then
that you have to give them part of your
merch going forward there's all sorts of
really tricky things is to go into
negotiating a contract like that yeah so
even though even though like that wasn't
a show that made it past the initial
call for us like we felt a lot more
confident even like tiptoeing into that
world yeah and like negotiating and
knowing what to look out for and
everything yeah it was good yeah and
then I think the first time we hung out
was event called staffed at and it's
it's really more you know a lot of
industry yeah it's really more for like
people in the industry not so much for
like content creators but April had
heard about it because Brad Rodriguez
and Jon Malaki who are also makers you
know they have YouTube channels podcasts
Instagram makers in the space they were
going and it was in Austin and we're
pretty close sauce we're pretty close to
Austin so April is like hey you guys
should should come by for this event you
know and from Anna ball trades has come
is in town and so like she's gonna go oh
man we're gonna have like tell some
sketchy details of how he got in and
everything we're gonna come clean about
this you can if you have a youtube
channel even if it's small cuz we were
pretty small at the time you can get
like a media pass yeah and because
because it's free it really does bring
some nice publicity and it's for a very
it's it's with you something up
something that you you as someone who
like has some sort of like the social
media we try not to come across is
entitled I mean it's usually a really
good trade you know yeah yeah I know it
is a really a trade and like a lot of
events we'll we'll do this yeah um and
so we were like well maybe we'll see if
we can get me we just went very
confidently and we're like you know what
and we're skate
scenario it'll probably not be too much
we'll just pay to get in nobody'll know
it was like several hundred a person had
like be a member then you had to be like
a year-long member and then you had to
buy this ridiculous ticket it'd be like
four hundred dollars or something like
that it was like yeah it was crazy and
the only people like some of the people
that were there were invited by
companies like Diablo blades and all
that stuff so some of them had passes
from the companies who were doing demos
there and there was the two of us a nan
who didn't have tickets yeah I don't
know I remember how we got into the
after party yeah how did we get into the
main event we did some shenanigans with
badges and passes and stuff like that
there are some snares it might have been
the same thing we did to get into the
after party yeah it was we cuz you could
bring spouses there it was Evan and I
April and Brad and John yeah and three
people had passes and three did not and
three were male and three were female
yes so basically you pretended like you
were married to April yes and was
married to John and I was married to
Brad so we had to like get our name
passes and stuff and it was like really
like sketchy and like kind of awkward
and we didn't know I knew what they were
doing but like it all worked it was an
adventure it was a bonding experience it
was it was great struggling against
adversity of yes money going around and
like you know talking to different
potential sponsors and you know all of
that jazz that's what all of us do
behind the scenes a lot of time anything
actually came of it in terms of talking
to sponsors for us cuz it ended being
more you know it must be for like
YouTube yeah it was so strange because
on the consumer side of things on the
consumer side of things is like people
kind of understand what YouTube is and
what our market can bring to
he's about like kind of that sumers that
watch this kind of content on YouTube
after all business to business not
business to consumer so it was it wasn't
the right fit for us really but we got
some good experience of talking it was a
fun adventure it was totally worth the
time also ended up because we were gonna
like drive an hour to stay at my parents
house oh yeah I'm like oh man so we
ended we stayed out till like midnight
or something like that so late night can
you imagine that
so late we shared like one drink but so
we end up having an impromptu sleepover
with Anne and April so we all shall room
the four of us yeah and then was there a
second day after that or did we just
peace out after that I don't even know
it was a hazy memory it was a fun
adventure that was one of our it was one
of our earlier events and it really the
event wasn't it wasn't about the event
it was just felt like hanging out I'm
glad we got to hang out there yeah yeah
but it was also so after that you know
we haven't hung out too much we did go
up there once for a spoon carving oh
that wasn't that's why we were there for
a second oh yeah I was like something
else happened so um so Anne was gonna
teach April how to carve spoons yeah and
we kind of just like tagged along
because I'll be fun
yeah and man hand carving and hand tools
are a lot of work and they're very hard
I'm sorry Ann well so we don't have the
tools anymore
yes a man brought all of her fancy tools
and we couldn't do it in the 7 hours
[Laughter]
going through the whole process of like
you know we we chainsaw down tree that
was in April's yard
and then we slice on the bandsaw and
stuff and we learned some about like the
grain and hand carving and all that jazz
so the ones we ended up carving were not
the one we chopped down oh yeah yeah
yeah cause it wasn't like the right
level of green or it wasn't yeah we were
working in an ideal like circumstances
for carving yes I'm carving like walnut
yeah that was like all dry green carving
is evidently oh no there's there's a lot
that goes into hand woodworking but
anyway should we jump into the interview
with April yeah yeah let's go into the
back into it let's just jump right into
it doing it right if you want to talk
fighters talk the talk yeah guys this is
a public service announcement so I think
the main thing that we wanted to kind of
get your opinion on is about building
your shop because that is amazing and we
sometimes in the future want to do that
shop yeah expressing your head currently
yeah yeah you're booked your rooms
they're like robot room yeah and the
other ones dedicated to of the three
bedrooms there's one bedroom there's one
robot room there's one office and then
our entire garage we just gave up on
ever parking in there it's like we're
having that one episode where we did it
we did our garage we park our cars there
after so naively thinking that we're
gonna keep it that way in the future
were set up in the front yeah no no no
it's pretty bad what do you want like
organizing how to jump into it what's
budget what's it like what were some of
the things I like looking back on that
you wish you had have known any like
like oh I should have done this or like
this was ended up being way harder than
I thought or way more time-consuming
okay yeah okay I tell you right on the
spot it's great I did a lot of research
pretty much if there was a shop series
on YouTube I watched it and I mean it's
okay but honestly it's just a big
rectangle and I didn't I don't want to
get super segmented and have a bunch of
different rooms like I wanted a big
space and then just to be able to move
and like maybe do like removable
curtains like I just want very flexible
open space so then if you take it in
that direction the main thing that you
have to figure out is how big do you
want it and then what what is that
displacement like length and width and
once you get that everything else is
just is it wood or metal and then it
becomes like way more simplified for you
but the things that I wished I would
have known right off the bat is don't go
through a general contractor for a grand
greed guy for oh I did everything myself
and I knew I was going to except for the
slab I wanted to hire that out yeah I
went through a GC and they charged about
$15,000 just for contacting the concrete
guys yeah so I mean like the concrete
guys I couldn't if I would have done a
little bit of research just to go
directly to them I paid a GC just 15
grand just to call up as dude that's
crazy hey this is this is the site that
you need to be at you know what I mean I
always wonder about general contractors
the band's like I'm the type like I
didn't want a wedding planner I was like
I'm gonna do it I don't wanna be charged
with that stuff and I feel like if we
were ever doing a big home renovation
where we did have to outsource something
yeah I would be tempted to be our own
general contractor but then like you
know it's a baby city you want to do but
it's also it's like I think that
sometimes they're charging for their
experience of like first easy to do this
and then this I'm like major steps up to
like if I were gonna be doing the
framing the roof and like pretty much
until it was a weather thing then you're
going through a GC and 1u because those
are all different crews keeping your
scheduling and then keeping them
accountable I will pay you to babysit
and to do that for me but just pour in
the concrete that's all I want you for
no I can do the research for finding the
concrete
crew yeah save myself $15,000 in and
take it from there you know what I mean
that's crazy and the only reason I know
that is because the concrete crew gave
me the invoice that they were before for
the GC what's his charge the general
contractor and I was really confused
about why he gave it to me in the press
I think it was just a mistake how much
money I just like spent over that I
didn't necessarily need - Wow - that was
a big thing but honestly everything else
from the shop it took about as long as I
was thinking it was as hard as I was
thinking which most recently heard yeah
it was very hard but it was a well the
hard part is it's two giants hast not
only building the drop which is
difficult in itself but then capturing
and producing the videos on how to tell
this massive story well and you last a
decent amount of footage right and I did
from the most important like framing and
trusses yeah well okay I remember you
texted or Instagram yesterday and like
the pain I felt it was so tangible cuz
that's like the worst thing and
especially during the big steps of
framing and setting trusses thankfully I
was able to string together and and that
taught me a really valuable lesson on
just how like much of a good story you
can tell we had little nuggets yeah I
mean now anytime I have like a glitch
I've actually thanked myself it's fine
I've done worse you've already gone
through the worst case scenario you we
went through it like it's still a good
story yeah with a little bit that I was
able to recover and I was like okay if I
hadn't known that you'd lost footage
watching the video I wouldn't have known
yeah you know it cuz it seems and
there's maybe more of you talking
directly to the yeah I'm right in that
video than a normal video but it just
seemed like that was fitting because it
was such a big story to tell to tell you
know what I mean yeah like I would've
done maybe it's like a good exercise it
was yeah I taught me a valuable lesson
I don't I don't really sweat it and it
also has me cutting back on the amount
that I'm capturing especially recently
did a bans on milk yeah another huge
undertaking and like I didn't film so
much and I just yeah I was thinking
myself this is okay because I know that
I'm only gonna be using that 15 seconds
there and then I have this
over here and that's gonna accumulate to
the two minutes that I need you tell
this one big stuff you know and every
hour of footage you record is more - at
it yes yeah yeah the more you before the
more work it is so for the band somehow
that was you matrimony Johnny Johnny
Jenny JD so is that the biggest like
in-person collaboration you've done like
with the most people yeah I mean other
than the time that you all came with a
on yeah this was like I think the first
collaboration that I actively plans like
I don't do a lot of collaborations so
yeah it was big and now I'm like so onto
the idea of let's do this traveling
thing oh yeah what's the next big thing
that somebody needs help with that like
six of us can get together like Jimmy
doing that you know at EP erection yeah
the concept like in my shop wasn't on my
home property I would have loved to just
say any content creator that wants to
show up and help ya with it but it would
just at that point and be in the time
frame like we would have been in each
other's way you know I mean yeah I do
like the idea of like a barn raising
hey wanna shop we've got of it because
we wanna be if we are gonna go through
the trouble of moving we want to be
somewhere where we do in more space yeah
I can't do a big shop because we're in
the suburbs right now and you're like no
also we've evaluated like where in the
world do we want to live and like every
time we travel I mean of course
California is so nice but this way way
it's like it's so impractical and have
the price and this release price yeah
and also constructing stuff there I mean
Ben you ADA that his his series that he
did and like he had to put sprinklers in
they wouldn't let him build like a small
thing like all of the trouble he went
through because it was in California was
just like money money money money money
on top of money alright quick aside Ben
you ADA he has a channel called homemade
modern but he actually made an entire
new channel called
it's for his tiny house the modern home
project the modern home project yeah I
totally knew that
no but it's it's really cool he built a
shipping container a tiny house in the
not tiny tiny house but like kind of
tiny house yeah well he intended it for
it to be tiny but also but actually
California wouldn't allow him to make it
as tiny as he wanted that - yeah which
is crazy and he has a whole channel
about that home yeah covers up from
beginning down it's a shipping container
house he built it out in the desert it's
super cool it's so crazy
um we'll link that below yeah just to
give context for talking about yeah yeah
but we should we should have him gone
some time till I talked about not only
that whole experience but also starting
a new channel or a series that's like a
risky move but it's working well for him
outside of the city limits no
restrictions the only thing I had to go
through some sort of like actual
structured process was to bring power in
that's only because I had a new pole and
get a 200 amp service yeah but really
the the area that you're in is probably
one of our ideal areas I mean close
close to big cities close enough that if
you ever need something from there you
can get it but also a big enough little
city that you still have access all the
things you want and restaurants when you
need it and stuff like that like project
supply runs yeah that's really cool but
with the shop it y'all did that how fun
would it be like to you every single
week bring in like a new five or six
people I love the idea because the
bandsaw no it was it was hard work to
constrict such a large thing or confine
it to five days yeah it made us all it
was a lot of fun yeah I think another
thing that's so crazy is every time we
we meet up with people in real life and
we're working together seeing how they
film seeing how they go about their task
process seeing like all of their
workflow I'm like oh I get it now you
know and it's so hard to do this without
being there and seeing it so JD is a
metal welding fabricator
professional con for the first time yeah
yeah exactly
so but he's just in a completely
different space even though he's still
like using his hands and tools yeah and
one of his go-to tools is a laser
measure you know a point-and-shoot tells
you and like at one point when it's a 12
foot bed by 6 feet wide so it's a big
thing to try to get into square and take
diagonals on Matt Matt and I we're
pulling out our tapes to try to get
diagonals and check for square JD pulls
out this laser measure and checks it and
checks it and it's just he's pointing
and shooting it and I'm like whoa you
just boom you know there's nothing Billy
and then you did it like six or seven
times throughout the project where you
just like really implemented this tool
that I I mean I know that it's useful
but I've never seen it implemented in
baking so I never associated it with how
useful and now it's like I'm getting one
of those and I'm gonna like why would I
not use this direct measure instead of
having to hook on you know yeah and we
always come back with tool list we're
like oh let's get more tools every time
we're into someone else's shop and stuff
yeah
sorry hello okay we're good so we're
talking about tools we're talking about
shops we're talking about builds and
collaborations and all of that stuff
like someone who you haven't
collaborated with I have a collaborator
with the majority of people you know
what it means that yeah and like I never
I never tried to think I want to
collaborate with this person so what can
I make yeah if it comes up like I did my
shop build with George yeah
and that just I just treated very
organically I needed to build a shop
yeah I knew my buddy George was a framer
so I said how about you come in on it
you know what I mean like yes we're in
the neck of the woods so I said hey you
want to come over for the spoon yeah I
just treat things like really
willy-nilly like but I love the idea of
collaborating it's just so much work and
effort effort into it I just let it
happen and if it happens and I want to
pursue it then I then I then I chase
after it yeah one thing I was curious
about is we're really we really like
that our shop is right on our like on
our house we you know we can go do a
paint finish or whatever and we can go
cook a meal or edit or whatever go down
in your PJs yeah exactly so do you find
like that slight separation kind of nice
in some way cuz like when you leave
you're kind of done but it's still so
close that it's kind of convenient I've
never had like before whenever my shop
was attached I've never had an
association of I'm out I'm outside of my
home it's now work time like I work all
the time like you guys and so it it
would be nicer if the shop were closer
to the house just so that it could make
that transition to throw on an extra
coat of finish easier or if I left my
laptop down there or whatever it is or
my iso tunes then I don't have such a
long thing but it's just not practical
to build such a like my shop is bigger
than my house to it and I think I think
it's fine either way
oh yeah yeah because I was thinking like
sometimes it's I was thinking daily a
slight distance might be beneficial to
us because we have a hard time stopping
yeah
the problem is like even if you stop in
the shop you have your laptop with you
and then you can just edit or it doesn't
really help as much as we might think
yeah I don't think so but I mean if
you're gonna build a bigger shop than a
two-car garage then aesthetically it'll
look better and I always like I even
building my shop I was thinking about
resale value for the property and my
house and it just made sense to do a
separate structure yeah yeah I even
thought like once like let's just build
a big barn and in the corner let's build
a little house where it's two storey or
like gym you just did like it will be
two storey I know so that that's
something although I wouldn't I wouldn't
enjoy that because in a way always be
like if he's working downstairs and
you're upstairs trying to sleep or vice
versa
I just I want to be able to blare music
and use my tools and not have to worry
yeah DC you know
yeah that's chair I hope you guys end up
moving to the to the local area but you
just can't sell anybody where it's at
yeah the local area local watering hole
us what one thing that's interesting is
I mean I think that at a certain point
will stop growing our tool collection
but have you found that having more
space do you think do you ever think
that you might fill it all the way up
there's any amount of space that you
could have that you're never gonna
eventually fill yeah and that's like
whenever I build stuff I'm still always
thinking what's the limit like what's
the most functional how do I utilize
this space best for this and people are
like why are you worrying about it like
you have enormous space but it's like
yeah but eventually it will get full
yeah so by me being efficient from the
very GetGo
it's just pushing off that deadline I
have more space I'll do the bandsaw milk
to yourself I've only been using tools
for five years and look how much I've
accumulated yeah like oh it's crazy i
thing about it is and and how many
different like niches and areas have I
developed into like I'm definitely not
done right and two new things like I
might get into leather work and then I
also might get into sewing just those
two things alone are like different
sections material storage in work area
and like cutting all I like and then and
then what my shop is now I just got into
a CNC Joanne it's like I I'm already
seeing how
I might have built it too small it's
like the the more space you have the
more efficient you can be you know cuz
like you have everything set up
everything that's good to go and if you
have to put everything away we have to
play a game of Tetris between every
project actually it's more of a game of
like move things from one surface to
another surface is a dangerous like my
shop is huge so it can be efficient yeah
it's gonna take me a long time to get it
efficient like right now I don't know
where my jigsaw blades are you know what
I mean like those small things my
chisels because the space is so large
that and I don't I don't have I'm not
set up yet or such a large space and
it's not like I set on my hands like I'm
actively doing one if not two or three
projects a week yeah
and I've been working on it steadily for
close to a year now and I'm still very
far away from like I don't have a spot
for my chisels you know what I mean so
it's it's a trade-off a small space I
think it makes you more resourceful yeah
but a large space just it will take you
time in order to get to that efficiency
level yeah I mean I think each leads to
unique content opportunities yeah which
are opportunities in some ways you know
I have an unrelated question when you
got here and they're like hey can you
fill in for Anne's talk it's just it's
about multiple revenue streams so again
I've been doing it for I mean years now
I know about talking business so yeah
sure put me on I mean it is stressful
being up on stage seeing a bunch of
eyeballs instead of just a flip around
screen I find a camera is so much easier
to chat with but yeah but yeah it was
fine you know what wasn't you stressed
about it I love passing along
information from the business side or
the project working so I think you were
one of the first people who like helped
us out with really figuring this out
well I remember we had a call to ask you
about TV stuff because we had been
contacted oh yeah was that a TV show and
we were like what are we doing like some
TV stuff recently we should ask her
maybe she'll talk to us what really
helped I mean like we told the story in
an earlier podcast where they were like
well you
exposure you know will help you get
exposure you know I'm like yeah it's
football yeah all sorts of different
ways and it's crazy to think about
though seems so long ago yeah I mean
kinda think two or three years
I mean guy was like two years ago yeah
yeah that's that that's the whole that's
our whole thing buddy well hey we don't
wanna keep you for too long there's a
lot going on out there but thank you so
much for joining us
so one thing we didn't really cover it
in the chat with April is what we
actually want in our shop you know like
what features do we want how big do we
want it all that's let's just go crazy
cuz like there is like an equilibrium
like our two-car garage is too small yes
a giant warehouse is too big yes but
like like as I think about like a bigger
and bigger and bigger space I don't
there's really two many downsides except
for heating and cooling and the cost of
it cuz like like more space just means
more backdrops more sets more like one
of the things I would be most excited
about is having like better backdrops
for ya and then we gives roll whatever a
thing we're doing like we can't have
like mobile work things like we have
like an entire woodworking like mobile
group like a whole metal working mobile
group and like a whole mobile just like
like arts or crafts or whatever and we
can set up in front of different
backgrounds so it's like we have one
whole wall just full of backgrounds yeah
like a really wide white one like a
green one like one that's decorated like
a set you know yeah it's kinda like
we're talking about like you know when
people are doing like TV shoots and
stuff like that how they have like a
soundstage yeah I you see the giant
soundstage with different backdrops in
the workshop inside of it but I wouldn't
want it I don't actually want it to look
like a set though like and I what do one
want anything to be too perfect no no
not too perfect I mean just by the
nature of who I am it won't be perfect
don't worry about that I know don't
worry no that's true but it would be it
would be nice to have better backdrops
that's what one of the things we've
struggled with in our video everything
is just you in such a small space
everything's chaotic all the time and
it's really hard for like carve out a
little area to film in you basically
just shove everything else behind the
camera is so visually cluttered yeah
but then like as soon as I turn the
camera you see all the chaos yeah but
also it's like you know our shop is I
think 20 by 20 or so yeah like 8 feet
this is this this green screen behind us
that's 8 feet and that barely contains
us within this frame so 8 feet isn't
wide enough to like really have a
filming dret backdrop you almost need
like 12 feet yeah in order to really
film something realistically that that
shows us shows what we're doing in the
has enough room for us to work like a 8
foot long bench and a 12 foot long
backdrop that's kind of what we need
yeah and we just don't have that spare
space because all of our wall is full of
very important things like shelves and
you know well just all sorts of crap now
but when we renovate one day it'll be a
little more organized and can condensed
but but so but if we were gonna start
from scratch
aside from backdrops what kind of things
would you do um let's see I think that
would set up stations where everything
is out and ready because right now
everything is in boxes everything is in
containers everything is put away and
getting that out getting it prepped
pulling it up on the thing plugging it
in and all of that stuff that's you know
it's all little things it's it's like
I'm lucky that we have them and I'm
lucky that we can do it but it's it's
inefficiencies and I think that making
the shop as efficient as possible is the
number one priority
I would like to have a room for the
robots a room for the robots I mean we
don't see real storage room that way we
don't have to have the robots in our
guest room
yeah anymore like my mom's in town right
now
you know I'm one of Jellico if you
haven't seen gel coat whatever he's a
really cool maker he just made a knife
and everything recently but one of his
earlier videos was him setting up his
dream workshop and he can't did it
similar to how we would want to do it
but um one of the things that he did
which I thought was really interesting
is he bought supplies in bulk and I had
like kind of one of everything so it's
like you know he got a big storage area
for all those screws and he bought like
like the the screw that he's gonna use
from now forward like probably a nice
star drive or something and he got it
and all of the sizes and all of the
lengths so he set up his own little yeah
like like Lowe's within his shop the
kaitlin's like that buying stuff
preemptively that you don't need that to
me just says like you're gonna have this
forever never use it yeah maybe I mean I
think if you get well you've done enough
projects and you know like in 90% of my
projects I use these two types of screws
yeah yeah but like just buying not
preemptively I think that yeah like I
think now getting like enough storage
and like you know we're always gonna
need to buy horse so just having some
two by fours on him yeah but you know
what about like eight two by fours and
so I'm like you know plywood that we can
just like pull down for whatever - we
have a small car and it's yeah delivery
truck bring like whatever we would need
for like a year you know what I mean but
like things like this like looking at
efficiency I think that'd be the goal of
the workshop have like you know right
now our drill press is underneath our
workbench not plugged in like so our
tools aren't plugged in because it's
like we have contractors on it's like
buried it's under the X because under
the x-carve and it's like by getting the
proper tools everything arranged ideally
so that we can just go you know I mean
we spent a lot of time and
of course there's time like before and
after every project cleaning up and
stuff and setting up but so much of our
time isn't just about like cleaning up
the mess it's about like reefing angling
the entire back into its storage
locations yeah you know it's like during
a project we pull things out and then
after the project we have to put them
all back and then pull out the next set
of things yeah you know it's not the
most efficient and for us I mean the
whole goal is to make videos to make
things to share with you guys and it's
like there's no benefit to like you know
the benefit of cleaning up is you have a
cleaner shop and we're organized and
stuff but it doesn't really affect our
output well and that's what I'm saying
is it the cleaning up you have to do
regardless but the rearranging of your
shop in order to like set up for
different projects that's the stuff that
I would like to eliminate eliminate
proper dust collection in all the places
and stuff you know so like some some day
we might move because we're not in a
space where we could expand mm-hm
our shop but it's also hard because like
I really like our house I like our house
we've been fixing about we've been
putting so much effort into it I know
not even not even just since starting
the channel since we bought the house
we've been putting a lot of effort into
fixing it up and so it's kind of like
the the deeper we go into renovating it
the harder it's good impedance but also
it might be nice to start over with all
of the skills and experience that we
have now it's like our attic is a mess
of like you know all of the wires are
all over the place all of the AC ducts
are just like not in the best shape and
everything and if we could start over
and do try to like do things right like
do things proper because like you know
in the attic this is I'm just using the
attic as an example because it's pretty
bad but in the Attic like all of the
cables are just on the ground they
should be like up in the ceiling along
like you know properly cable managed and
where everything can be seen not tripped
on not accidentally cut you know all
these things like that if we could start
over and do things like right from the
beginning or if we move in and we had to
fix things up we can fix things up to a
higher standard
more about like like oh well I know we
get a bunch of boxes now cuz we get a
bunch of later
we're always ordering you tools they're
like sponsors are sending us stuff I'm
like okay now I know that we need to
have like some kind of area either in
our office or next workshop or whatever
where we have like our like in box but
in box of boxes are receiving bangs like
that that we I wouldn't have thought
about or even looks like house things in
general it's like before we moved in to
this house we didn't get as many things
done as we wanted to like we got the
floors done we got some of the floors
under needed the rest later but like
like oh you're thinking things but like
for example it would have been great to
like first off before we did the floors
like you know strip all of the popcorn
off all the walls on the ceiling like
properly prep all of the walls and
everything and like get them like the
finish we want like the flatness that we
want and and everything like that before
we do the floors and then do the floors
and then all of that jazz you know there
have been so many so many times I wanted
to like add like cool was it wainscoting
wainscot yeah - the walls are like a
really cool trip chair rail or something
okay there's like a lot of really cool
stuff you can do but it only works if
you don't have popcorn on your walls
popcorn on your walls and you have to
like scrape it all off or cover it it's
like pretty intense like there's some
like like bumps there more than an
eighth of an inch like I'm not not a
half inch but maybe three-eighths of an
inch like protruding from the wall
you're like aggressive aggressively
popcorn that's one of the biggest things
I felt like cuz I I would really like a
lot of DIY blogs and I felt like I had a
pretty good idea of like what to look
for in terms of bones of a house and
what was just like cosmetic stuff that
shouldn't you shouldn't let it be a big
deal oh man one of the things that we
saw when we were house hunting we
actually
we should tell the whole story about
house hunting and then like how he
almost got like an investment property
and all of that jazz we'll save that for
say that for another story time but one
of the houses we walked into on the
ceiling now that's some aggressive pop
Corning oh they were like they're like
razors I was like a razor ceiling lights
I feel like if I had have jumped I would
have cut my head open in multiple places
they were sharp they were like I don't
even know what type of ceiling that was
not even popcorn it was like jagged
edges of razors on the ceiling I
underestimated how much of a big deal it
would be to fix anyways yeah I think
like I do foresee us moving eventually
yeah mostly because of the works mainly
because of our job and how our job is
our house and our house is our job yeah
yeah now the thing one thing we're
considering is like if we move do we
keep this house and rent it out have it
as an income property that's what I
would like to do yeah I think that I
might like to do that too and now it
would be like even more work but it
isn't nice but I think we would probably
just like get a management company so
you don't have to yeah so we can keep on
like you know raising the value of the
house you know getting income from the
people living here and all of that and
when we pay off the house it'll just be
straight income and yeah value of the
house rising and stuff neighborhood it
had a really cheap price and a really
low interest rate so like if we can
afford to get in another house without
selling this one and we can you know in
terms of like having enough a down
payment then we would like to keep this
one yeah
I think I'd be cool plus like then it'll
make it less hard to move away who's our
first house first house to start
collecting them fix up a house move on
to the next one rent it out like a lot
of work no I don't actually want to do
that like when anytime we're at a point
where we're like we should move
no pizza keeping the old house the old
one yeah yeah and renting it out yeah
yeah is interesting to think about it
right now what other crazy things would
you want in our dream shop that's life
I'm just kidding I mainly honestly I
mean I feel like some of the
organization stuff is kind of obvious
like having you know stuff we already
talked about how much space to be
organized and be more efficient
honestly the stuff that I get really
excited about is just making it look
really cool you know I just wanna have
so much work on the walls yeah so much
of what we do is visual you know and
it's boosted up by having visual
interest videos how much time we spend
in the shop we spend a lot of time I'm
the type of person I get a lot of
anxiety if things aren't organized like
like a decent amount of anxiety I'm
sorry it's you know it gets to me and so
um but also like I get a lot of
enjoyment of being out of space that I
think looks really cool so this is this
is this room was getting better better
this room is getting better and better I
do helps a lot yes um but um sorry I was
having the desk like saying a desk but
yeah so I I just think about having a
really cool workshop look like I love
Laura comps workshop they look so cool I
love dealing with her new workshop yeah
what's so interesting is I think that
it'd be it'd be interesting to see like
what your ideal shop would be because
you're drawn to two different aesthetics
I feel you're drawn to like on one side
a really clean aesthetic where
everything is I kind of organized and
put away and there's like white and
green and like it's nice and everything
has implants yeah like you know like
plants and stuff and like like nicely
framed art you're drawn to that
aesthetic you're also drawn to like the
like classical eclectic where everything
is kind of a little bit crazy and like I
think I can merge them okay oh wow
picture you have like a brick wall yeah
Brit painted white okay so you have like
that kind of texture a little clean but
not too clean you have art on the
King lights string oh yes yes lights
maybe some hanging faux plants yeah no
one's gonna keep those alive but then
you also like you're like a dust blower
and blow them off every now but then and
then like pegboard
well nicely organized tools yeah
but also like on the wall we might have
displays of some of the stuff we've
built so maybe like a propane blaster
yeah you know you know but that sounds
great I don't know yeah then we can do a
whole project about this display and
then when we get tired of it we can just
move down the wall and do another
display have different sets totally yes
I think that like for us it's like go as
big as we potentially could yeah for the
next one yeah yeah why we're thinking
about moving farther from the city one
thing that's interesting is I think that
having a long and skinnier one would
work for us
so we can have a law like a lot of wall
without the space getting tu-tu-tu-tu-tu
big that's true because like wall space
is the most valuable space yes we had a
big rectangle I think we would almost
have to make like little cabinet
stations or even like false walls just
to put stuff on against or stuff you
know oh well I can we had a UH I'm being
like a big long I know but that's not
typical typically what you'll find is
there's a big square a big rectangle
filling a shop but a rectangle is a well
but no no no no I'm gonna sing like a
big like a big long lowercase L so
aligned yeah just like a line just like
a big straight yeah I'd like a rectangle
but it's like a big like skinny but long
thing you that's long sure that would
build it ourselves we might very well
can help us but we might be in a
position where there's like a building
on a
yeah so yeah if it is a square just
divide it in half so then you have two
long rectangles within there maybe or
yeah um you could even like have I
imagine having like really really big
like tall work tables in the middle of a
big square that have big storage
cabinets and you have like your tools
against the walls but you have storage
in the middle you know piont a big giant
island yeah yeah yeah I'm just getting
excited and I don't I don't want to move
but I am pretty excited all right you
know time it is now guys as we mentioned
earlier we're gonna be reading lyrics
and we're gonna be guessing what the
song is should I go first
if you have your list ready all right
whoever loads the list first wins ha ha
ha I got it alright ready yeah
it's my turn to fly proving ground
tonight try to be the best that I can of
going to be a man only humans can
understand I fill my lungs with fear and
I exhale
oh gosh oh I know I know I feel like I
know this wait
Prue proving ground tonight yeah
proving ground tonight proving ground
proving ground does that even mean it's
my time to fly proving ground tonight
try to be the best that I can
I've grown to be a man only humans can
understand such a good soundtrack the
whole movie was really great except for
this they've named the planet Bob
nothing gets Bob Bob's a cool name but I
mean come on that part never made sense
to me because it was such a serious
movie yeah yeah it was a really good
movie and that scene right there where
they're flying through the clouds and
everything like that
oh yeah okay because there's like a lot
of like more like deep in 3043 the
refugees survived the whole of humanity
lies in my hand that might have given it
away a little bit but I couldn't like
give it away too much but I didn't start
with the very beginning of the song
which is like you know yeah so I did a
good job
I'll do one more with a little sweetness
and simple numbing me yeah stumble till
you crawl whoa oh oh oh sinking into
sweet uncertainty is that the chorus or
a verse I just chose a random place come
on come on start in the beginning you're
gonna know
what a simple sweet and simple numbing
me what a dizzy dance whoa this
sweetness will not be concerned with me
okay you're gonna you're have to give
know the sweetness will not be concerned
with me can you give me like a genre of
music um kind of like our our teenage
years okay some kind of rock are you
listening whoa Oh sweetness by jenni an
interesting note before we like dive
into this it was really interesting
thinking of like what songs to choose
because depending on who's listening to
this and what age their what age they
are and everything it could be like like
there's they could have no chance
whatsoever to get it because we want you
guys to be able to play along - yeah
well like it's interesting because I
think that when we were teenagers
everyone our age knew the songs that
were like the songs yeah you know what I
mean but I feel it was harder and you
you got two CDs I feel like an old fogey
now there wasn't this streaming thing
going on and stuff it's not just
streaming it's also like YouTube and
anyone can make music now and that music
can get really popular and everyone's
musical interests are just like
expanding so much there's no like okay
that's guaranteed overlap there's less
guaranteed overlap these days which is
crazy you know so it's like I chose some
older things I chose something from pop
I chose something so they're just like
thought would be funny to say like tea
like like tempt you with like these
songs like where you kind of know them
but you don't know them
just trying to make it like interesting
they let us know how many you guys get
let us know if we're like completely off
your entire like genre what if you have
any requests for like genres mmm if they
do a song requested it then both of us
will see no and then I think of all the
times you screwed me over but had me
believing it was something it was always
something I'd done
sounds like an avro song or something
like that but I don't want to live that
way reading into every word you say you
said that you could let it go and I
wouldn't catch you hung up give me is
honor its kind of indie sounding and
it's not that old
[Music]
you can get addicted to a certain kind
of sadness like resignation in the end
when we found out that we could not make
sense well you said that we could still
be friends but I'll admit that I was
glad it was over some Lincoln 82 or
Lincoln Park okay a little bit a little
stronger ahead because right now I'm
pulling up a zero but you didn't have to
cut me off make out like it never
happened and that we were nothing
is it like Taylor Swift
[Laughter]
about those two lines I said I'll
continue what don't you answer the
chorus regarding the song and I don't
even need your love but you treat me
like a stranger and that feels so rough
[Laughter]
I think I impress you so much the first
time we played this you thought I was
gonna be better and this is what it
really is mostly gonna be like sing a
little
sing this a little bit know if I sing it
you'll immediately I'll finish the
forest no you didn't have to stoop so
low have your friends collect your
records and change your number and then
change your number sorry there's a bath
I guess that I don't need that though
now you're just somebody that I used to
know somebody that I used to know you
didn't have to cut me my cheeks are
getting like sore from smiling this
there's definitely Lions that I cannot
say I'm never gonna catch my breath say
goodbye to those who knew me boy was ia
fool never gonna catch them that song
was just epic let's get down to business
to defeat the Huns
it's like reading the lyrics really made
me want to watch that movie oh yeah we
should maybe just go back and watch some
Disney classic my brother and his friend
Ben recently and they quoted it they're
like decide on you yeah all right this
might be really easy this might be
really hard more than our our never ever
after work is over oh my god oh my god
work it make it oh it was like because I
was like these words sound familiar but
they don't actually make hard to guess
it's not to the rhythm yeah right yeah
hmm standing there alone the ship is
waiting all systems are go are you sure
control is not convicted but the
computer has the evidence no need to
abort the countdown starts watch I'm
gonna maybe you have something the
subconscious going on my head maybe yeah
yeah I mean sweetness is just random
yeah yeah I'm listening to like high
school we've been like going back in
time okay
hot like wasabi when I bust rhymes big
like LeAnn Rimes because I'm all about
value
Burt camp furs got the mad hits you try
to match wits Oh
Macklemore no no no thank you try to
hold me but I bust through oh man I
thought was Macklemore
all right keep on going so hard for me
to not sing this gonna make a break and
take a fake ID like a stinkin Aiken
shake it's like white person rap I think
I might know the guy I've ever got his
name okay
it's not if the artist is not a guy's
name all right
it's like the name of the group yeah
okay I'll do a different section if some
sections I definitely can't you hold it
now and watch the hoodwink as I make you
stop think you'll think you're looking
at Aquaman
I summon fish oh I do not remember this
part at all although I like the shall
they Swiss I like the sushi because it's
never touched the frying pan okay give
me a part we're like I might have a
better chance at this
it's been one week to the next
yeah chickadee China the Chinese chicken
you have a drumstick and you brain size
to watch the next bells and the lights
on
first Alameda Sun hook so I can go
through some like Harrison Ford again II
fan to France to proxy I'm changing like
six guarantee this essay the curse ow I
be mad films care to make them did they
have a samurai gonna get a side a better
cuz up another comment ending up so my
own son I was flying off their backs we
gotta get into Sailor Moon cos a cartoon
is got the boom anime babe they made me
think the wrong thing I can literally do
the whole like a really bad sitting
dance actually no I still do I still do
I pride myself if I can memorize a song
that is really really fast yeah she
likes it I really like it she really
liked it if something comes out it's
really fast I kind of have to memorize
it like I'll look up lyrics like when I
was younger if a CD came with the lyrics
in the CD you know some it would come in
like it would have the lyrics sometimes
if you're lucky I'd have a look at all
the songs sometimes I might just be like
five of the songs yeah but when I had
mmm-hmm cuz we didn't have internet you
know I think that we each get two more
songs and that's it we we're just gonna
start running over soon okay right here
my turn this is like a wild card you
might get it right away
you might never get it all right I'm
gonna start with like an easier one
because it's you just might not even
know the song at all and I know you know
it okay okay I'll start with a harder
part you asked for it love was changing
the minds of pretenders while chasing
the clouds away our hearts were ringing
in the key that our souls were singing
as we danced the night remember how the
star stole that night away but hey hey
hey BAE day yay I say do you remember
baby well if I keep on going I might
give it away
remember how we knew love was here to
stay now December found the love that we
shared in September Oh
September September yeah baby yeah say
do you remember bad
yeah yeah yeah bike but that's like I'm
reading it it's be a space yeah this
might this is way too easy I'm trying to
find like I'm trying to find like a hard
part but like we know all the lyrics to
this like all one can read it really in
a creative way where you mix up the
sentences like pacing even though she
moved away we always get two calls from
her daughter she has eyes just like her
father
yeah yeah yeah when we were just started
torturing I was very impressed
I really was yeah I want to cry too now
I could not do it I had to do it one of
these points very special song okay do
you want to do it a hard one yeah yeah
it's like you can't all right there's
literally no words there's literally no
words even if I try to like mix it up
okay going from like a very sentimental
song to another type of song ride my
little Pooh Bear want to take a chance
Julie yeah looks like what could I have
done my wuzzy womb illuzzi womb is so
good
silky smooth perfume some weird lyrics
as you chose that one to read it's so
good it's like so good yeah class
animals just all of it or that whole
album yeah see the thing that gets you
in trouble with these songs that I like
a lot is I i memorize them
okay what about what about one this is
really easy but also maybe hard maybe if
I choose a good part let me let me try
it one more time I want to roll him a
hard pair we will be a little gambling
it's fun when you're with me
I love it and baby when it's love slice
it up really poorly it's like Russian
roulette is not the same without a gun
[Music]
okay
your last your last go and then that
this ends it okay finish it ain't got a
care in the world but got plenty of beer
ain't got no money in my pocket but I'm
already here Macklemore and now the
dudes are lining up is this an old song
or new song I mean in the like time
period of songs we've done in this
episode it's viam medium okay so - mm
maybe it might be 2010 right I'll do
another section I'm talking pedicure on
our toes toes I'm talking pedicure on
our toes toes day I can do don't stop
make it pop yeah
no right attendee yeah there's a lotta
kitten doing that morning no one saying
do this now when I say that no one
saying be there oh no no you're right
you're right I was like why is this
sound weird when I read it
so there's mixing the lyrics with what
Zazu is saying oh no one saying do this
no one saying be there oh wait no this
is wrong my lyrics are wrong here well
cut that one out okay
no one here right here right here this
is a second yeah no I'm saying do this
do this I was like yeah that's it
no that's the end of the program good UI
honey one more one more
what's so funny is you gave me the pass
on that I knew I knew what the song I
knew it was Disney but I was having
trouble placing it I was like is that
mermaid is that Aladdin is that and I
was getting to Lion King but like you
gave to anyways a little early I would
have gone there okay I have one I'm just
gonna I can't do too many lines in a row
because of the cursing haha oh my so I'm
just gonna give you individual lines all
right get your towels ready it's about
to go down that's what that's a line
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy no
here's another line from somewhere else
in the song we're drinking santana champ
cuz it's so crisp go on hair literally
can't do like two lines in a row there's
that much cursing okay hey MA you could
see me now arms spread wide what I was
wide open
on the starboard bow yes Lonely Island
I'm on a boat that's good that's good
there are lots of lines you can't say
give away shape flipping copies that's
good okay so after all those songs what
do you think is gonna be stuck in your
head the most when we end this - still
Mulan montage that montage though yeah
so good well here let's get out to our
favorite things to the week oh yeah we
still got stuff to talk about
yeah come on yeah there you're their
favorite I like them too I was getting
so excited when I was like there's still
some that I'm like so excited to you I
didn't even get to all of mine I have
even more oh my gosh part 3 coming soon
one day some might not be the next time
oh I'm coming in time alright so what's
your favorite thing of the week Caitlyn
okay so it's we started playing this
game called unraveled it it's on rubble
to unravel to ttwo
really and its unravel unraveled yeah
unravel - that's on the switch I think I
might be on other platforms too but it's
so cute it's so cute it's a it's so I
think you can play it one player but
it's really great playing
to player it's a great couples game it's
not just like you know some some games
where you switch from one player to
player it's like you're still kind of
just doing the same thing and you could
like doesn't really change because you
have two people but with this it changes
so much in the way you have to like work
together because these two little
characters connected by a string and
you're like helping each other maneuver
through this world the whole game is
designed for two-player co-op basically
and it's it shines there yeah at times
it's so good it's cute it has a good
story it's fun there's good puzzles yeah
really great like chill puzzle game if
you want actual puzzle game um and it's
just super cute yeah we'll have a link
to it in the description down below
and we'll probably be playing it soon
yeah we're on the stream so my my
favorite thing is it's kind of lame kind
of a little bit lame but I've really
been having fun doing it it's not really
new social media platform but yeah like
people who have social media platforms
can start a Amazon store that has all of
their favorite stuff and I don't know
why but I just had a lot of fun
collecting all of the stuff from all of
our projects all the different things
categorizing them it's very visually
pleasing to see them all laid out that
you can shop yes there's different like
little categories that you can group
things under and you can also post a
photo and tag all of the products that
you used because we get a lot of
questions about like the camera or the
gear or the art supplies or the you know
tools and all of that and we put a lot
of time and effort and thought into like
what we buy and we try a lot of things
out so it's fun to share it with you
guys and it's just a really neat one
place one-stop shop for all of our
favorite Amazon stuff so yeah it'll be
the link will be down below but I'm
pretty sure it's just like amazon.com
slash shop slash evident Caitlyn so it's
a nice URL too and everything and we're
gonna keep that updated as we go forward
it's my new it's not my new favorite
thing but it's definitely I think of the
week yeah it's crazy too cuz like we
just started there and our things are
already getting like a lot of
engagements a lot of views and it's like
we're able to include it the link to our
videos and those like little image
- and everything and it's like what the
heck even is this is like this
completely untapped I know platform I
know like the modern maker guys are on
it yeah I haven't really heard of other
people doing it no it's so crazy it's
just like it's bonkers I don't know yeah
that's really bonkers yeah well thanks
so much for watching you guys I know
that our listening
whichever one you decided to do I know
that that we've gotten some questions
about when we're gonna do the how to
YouTube thing we're still deciding which
format works best we were gonna do video
then we're gonna do podcast they were
going back and forth so we're gonna be
recording a test of that coming up
soonish and then we'll let you guys know
as it progresses we haven't given up on
it we haven't stopped we're just moving
forward with it
even more in multiple directions we just
really want to be good yeah and we want
to do it once and be like done you know
there's a lot of work but thanks so much
for listening and we'll see you later
bye
[Music]